what's up army that's my uh that's my rm
impression oh what's up army
we're gonna watch one vocal and rap line
pizza i can't dude
oh my gosh yo what's up bts rv
oh my this is great juliette saro is
here
follow her on instagram today if you
guys haven't done so already
that's all she asks poses and priests
and nun outfits
bizarre can't even tell it's her
underneath the hoods hooded priests
that's not what it is anyway the last
time julia was people are really
yeah the last time
juliet was here she sent me a message
she said something along those lines i'm
paraphrasing i'm pretty
sure you said god damn it greg why
didn't we cover a bts because she's a
big
that's exactly what i said actually big
bts fan over here
so i was like okay she's here no matter
what before she leaves we have to at
least cover
one bts this must happen to keep her
happy we must keep her happy
yeah because right now the hooded priest
outfits aren't covering the bills
you know just a bts video every once in
a while so we're gonna watch a fun one
today since you've seen all the music
videos already
i mean i mean that makes sense like this
is the second it comes i've held off on
watching all the music videos
in case greg passed me one day when
vocal and rap line bts change roles
hashtag bts funny
[Music]
[Music]
space
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's trying he's doing his best oh no
he's trying his best
they're so cute
[Laughter]
foreign
it's not his calling
[Music]
what is he doing
i think he doesn't want to sign
autographs
[Music]
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
my favorite songs
dear god
[Music]
oh my god
oh i'll never have
as much fun with my friends in real life
[Music]
their roles are there for a reason
[Music]
from what i remember rap monster isn't
that bad of a singer he's a great singer
he's he's sung before
[Music]
[Music]
it's the one dance move i could kind of
kind of do
that will not be demonstrated here right
now
[Music]
i take that
[Music]
[Music]
you look so tense
[Music]
oh i like his shirt that outfit though
that's a great outfit
[Music]
there's something so contagious about it
[Laughter]
you can probably still freestyle better
than me
[Music]
me
[Laughter]
[Music]
me
[Music]
i'm in love with all of them me too
well you can't have them julia you can't
have them julian
[Laughter]
i love when they rap oh
[Music]
dude
[Music]
um
[Music]
i want to see what their closets look
like
you mean their stylist
[Laughter]
it's just a sliding closet door
smaller selection than you'd expect he's
great as a rapper
[Music]
is your favorite he's one of my
favorites yeah him and v
am i top two they're all oh my gosh what
a throwback
this is like their second release ever
i only saw this music video for the
first time like two months ago
it takes me back
forgot he wrapped in that
[Music]
i forgot he was such a good rapper what
[Music]
oh my god it was like 2014
oh my god this takes me back this is one
of my favorites
[Music]
oh man on a high note
so it sounds like you've been following
them since before they were
like the sensation that whoa this is
really caught in my hair i've been a
huge k-pop fan since i was in ninth
grade so over a decade
really yeah and so i was like into like
the second generation of kpop which is
like big bang
and 281 and girls generation shiny
um super junior yeah and it extended
past like kpop like ft island the rock
bands and stuff and so i
i watched their debut like i remember
they did in
2013 i think and i i watched their debut
like when i was like yeah they're
they're great i like them a lot so i saw
them in 2014 in korea
wow you saw these guys yeah i saw before
they were really famous here
it was a concert for new year's in seoul
2014 to
2015. yeah was the new year duck you
i know and then they exploded and i was
like i was here first
did you have that envious feeling of
like not envious but that feeling like
i knew them before when they were
underground a little bit i don't go
around
saying it because i'm not a you know
narcissistic
[ __ ] but
a little alone off camera she is on
camera yeah
yeah you won't get that five it's true
don't admit that k-pop became so
much more mainstream because of them
yeah they really did hit that stride
yeah it was crazy because they don't
even come from like one of the big three
entertainment companies jyp yg or sm
it was like this smaller company big hit
so it was like
whoa i'm sorry i'm most
expressive ever i have a lot to say
i think we've in total done six videos
in total together
and i was like whoa this is the most
this is the most expressive she's ever
been in you know a lot this is awesome i
mean kpop literally like
shaped my life really and it was so
influential
because i discovered it in ninth grade
which is when you're like developing
your interest
taste in men
like korean men i mean
it's mainly korean guys yeah i i mean
i hunted down koreans like when i was
when i was in college
out of context if you just take that
moment i hunted down
when i was in college like
when i was in well because my high
school had like no asians and so i was
like
really disappointed and then when i went
to community college
i was like there's gonna be koreans here
so i'm not as crazy as i sound right now
so i
joined the international club solely to
meet
koreans oh that's cool
but i did i had like some great korean
friends
that's awesome yeah and you still do
you've rejected your korean friends have
you injected yourself with korean blood
your dna i identify as oh yeah that's oh
sorry i didn't mean to offend you
so my ex was korean gotcha my eggs with
korean
and uh yeah and you just call them a
different bts name
i won't go there with
who's your favorite bts member that will
close this video
jungkook was my favorite he was like my
first favorite when they first debuted
and then i found out who was younger
than me so i was like oh maybe i'm not
allowed to have them that's my favorite
sure you are they're all younger than me
and they're all my favorite
no but he's still one of my favorites
him and v are my top two
i mean i love them all but him v and
then like rap monster probably
have you ever watched rap monsters like
singles yeah yeah
it's really impressive stuff really good
really proud i can't wait to rap battle
him one day um
yeah are you working on it yeah i'm
working on my tears
i'm working on uh how to cower and get
into the fetal position
i've already know how to lose in style
okay well i got this down
can't wait to watch it oh yeah no it'll
be my biggest performing video and last
performing video
all right guys well julia thanks for
bringing here your wisdom
your knowledge you're welcome your lust
for koreans
oh i'm glad we opened that door yeah
check out juliet if you're any korean
follower
if you're not followers subscribe to the
real rejects click the notification bell
hit the like button easily one of the
most fascinating conversations i've had
in a while on this channel
you're welcome patron of the day shout
out
sarah sarah sarah sarah campbell
sarah campbell sarah we're shouting you
out
sarah you get a special especially
sarah on the go so we're on the ground
sir hey sir
we're on the ground sarah
sarah she's our lovely friend from nova
scotia
we just learned where that is sarah from
nova nova scotia sarah
sarah scotia oh nova scotia i was
up there with your your passion and
psychology
passion and psychology and shrink us
like psycho
psychological horror films i've been
telling you
i really think you should get into
writing or filmmaking because of your
your passions you you combine them i
really think you can do it
i think you can do it sarah you put you
i really think you can do it sir
sarah and then we just can pursue
something crazy
and creative that is like not
just who to inappropriately decide not
to inappropriately
just think sir i believe i believe in
you
i believe in you we believe in you we
believe in you
we believe in you sarah you're the one
sarah